[Applaudissements]
n'aie pas peur des serpents en anglais
once par le fait alors c'est la pente
est d'accord elle sera donc avec telle
somme monfort est ce qu'on peut les
retrouver
s'il vous plaît j'adore cet onglet ah
oui ça lui va très bien ça lui est noir
elel sallaoui elle fait très bien
regarder l'épisode toujours classe a
alors dit moi alors oui alors il doit
rentrer dans la paix est rentré dans la
pièce rentrer dans la tête
allez-y rentrez rentrez au très fermé la
porte vers mais la porte des rebelles
apparaît sur des lits fermés la part
belle est le seul grand train et kate
qui en rentrent avec elle devrait faire
entre nexans et wendel sa rentrée avec
elle rentrera dès qu'elle allait fermer
la porte fermée à temps c'est pas vrai
et bon maintenant on pouvait les
enfermer personnes il y à des serpents
il y a des mygales il va falloir que
vous formiez une phrase en trouvant des
mots sous les mygales et les serpents
si vous arrivez à le faire et bien un
loup téléspectateurs gagnera une console
de jeu et nora et nelson c'est parti et
laura vous pouvez laisser tomber les
clés c'est parti on y va essayer de
trouver allez on y va il faut essayer de
trouver sous les animaux la démo c'est
que vous avez les mots vous allez devoir
trouver une phrase d'accord à les aider
moi je vais je bien commencé les équipes
a dès lors plus que je
les haisnois live aussi qu'il aura donc
soulez un de ses amis jaune et blanc
mais pas non mais si c'est en dessous
que ça je deviens deux écoles à trouver
à genève je n'ai je n'ai pas le courage
de mettre ma main dans le voit pas la
[Applaudissements]
gérer et ça se pose là bas on voit pas
ce qu'il a il ya une sorte d'énorme
arrêté deux adolescents ils estiment
qu'ils n'avaient pas vendu ce genre de
surprise moi je veux bien les a pas
collé dessus
nestlé pour m'aider le jeu ne marcherait
pas mais ça c'est soit tu verras ça
cheuveux pas les cheveux teints j'avais
peur des radars
adelson j'y vais j'y vais j'ai vraiment
bon sens vous y allez laden solo show
bien je veux vas-y vas-y j'ai gelé des
toits que rien du tout
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi alors des dessertes ans je
n'ai pas peur des charbons sega
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jon